hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I am
going to explain a 2022 American fantasy
movie called the school for good and
evil many years ago two brothers Rhian
and ROFL created a school to keep the
balance between good and evil in the
fairy tale World they kept the balance
for Ian's but things seldom stay that
way one time Rafal was bored and wanted
to spar with Rhian was tired of re and
giving Heroes the upper hand he used
blood magic and wanted evil to dominate
however in rhian's attempt to defend
himself ROFL off a cliff and seemingly
died years later in gavaldon a
friendship blossoms between Sophie and
Agatha the one obsessed with dresses and
princesses and the latter secretly
inherit witchcraft from her mother the
death of Sophie's mother made them close
since they were children they are mocked
by the whole village for being freaks
villagers even threatened to burn Agatha
and her family because they accuse her
of being a witch but Sophie always gets
her friends back they find comfort in
doauville's bookstore looking at the
freshly delivered Cinderella copy they
notice an sge or school for good and
evil stamp the clerk tells them that
years ago a village girl named Leonora
was wanted by the school during a red
moon was taken and then was never heard
from again
seeing it is one of the ways to get out
of the boring Village Sophie wishes to
be recruited by the school for good she
writes a letter to prove her good and
Noble qualities then hangs it by the
wishing tree the next day Agatha gets
Furious as Sophie wishes to get out of
town but she assures her friend she will
stay However her promise is already
granted just as the red moon covers the
sky Agatha discovers that her best
friend is about to leave a mysterious
figure takes Sophie away unwillingly
taking Agatha as she defends her friend
they are flown by s-t-y-mph or a
skeleton bird until they see the two
school buildings Agatha is dropped into
the school for good while Sophie is into
the school for evil they believe it is a
mistake the two friends meet the dean
for each of their schools Lady leso of
the Nevers leading the school of evil
and Professor dovey of the Evers leading
the school of good afterwards the
orientation program commences as the
leading school for the past 200 years
the boys from school of good demonstrate
their sort fighting skills Prince Ted
Rose the son of King Arthur gets his
solo moment he is enamored by Sophie's
Beauty and accidentally drops his Rose
onto Agatha even though Beatrix has
claimed him for himself in the evening
Agatha escapes from her sleeping
quarters to rescue Sophie she is
discovered by a cupid who wants to
punish her for exploring the ledge then
she goes inside a library she finds
dovey and lesso inside arguing whether
they have made the right decision on the
two friends after they leave raffle's
Spirit emerges he warns Agatha to stay
away from Sophie Agatha dismisses the
warning and continues her walk to the
school of evil meanwhile Sophie is
bullied by her friends one of them
Hester is about to drop her off the
balcony when she sees Agatha they
Embrace each other then decide to follow
the Schoolmaster riyan into his Tower
the Schoolmaster explains that their
stories have been written by the
historian who narrates fairy tales and
could not be easily changed except if
Sophie finds a true loves kiss true love
is something the evils do not possess
which will prove her innocence Agatha
and Sophie then make a mission to find
true love for Sophie the next day they
attend classes Agatha meets Gregor
during lunch a clumsy boy who was the
son of a prince but feels like he does
not belong there Sophie comes to her and
decides that Ted Rose is her true love
so she gives dagathal a letter to give
to him she tells her not to act weird
around him Ted Rose and Agatha talk and
he seems interested in her sense of
humor then they attend a class by gnome
Yuba in the blue Forest where they are
introduced to dangerous plants Gregor
who is afraid of blood cannot stand the
horror of the forest and runs away
unfortunately he is cursed his spirit is
taken and he magically disappears Agatha
watches him in horror meanwhile at the
school of evil Lessa wants students to
demonstrate their evil Powers Hester
threatens Sophie using her fiery Phoenix
Avatar but Sophie is saved by raffle
spirit in the form of a swarm of bees
leso takes Sophie away and warns her to
not speak of his name meanwhile the
Evers learn about the Wish Fish a school
of fish that grants wishes while
everyone wishes for true love Agatha
wishes for everyone to find a home the
fish then transforms into a girl who
failed the school a hundred years ago
she dies in Agatha's arms then s-t-y-mph
comes she recognizes it as Gregor but
Ted Rose heroically kills him Agatha
punches him in the cafeteria Sophie
finally meets Ted Rose she is then
punished by lesso who cuts her hair
because she does not want to embrace her
evil Agatha confronts Ted Rose afterward
and explains that he just killed Gregor
Sophie meets ruffle's reflection in the
mirror who convinces her that no one
believes her except him on their next
meeting Ted Rose is clearly drawn into
Agatha making Beatrix jealous the
students assembled to get their finger
glow and unlock their magical powers
Sophie now confident to embrace her evil
identity comes and steals everyone's
attention she gives a makeover to her
never friends and makes peace with them
however Agatha tells her that she has to
be good to win over tedro's heart the
two friends work together to charm Ted
rose with Sophie's archery skills Agatha
tricks the arrow to fly straight making
Sophie seem good because only an arrow
of pure heart can fly straight Ted Rose
is enamored by her and they begin dating
the whole school is sent into chaos as
they believe in ever and never dating is
not meant to be there is only one way to
settle the chaos which is the trial by
Tale Sophie and Ted Rose are to enter
the blue forest from different ends at
sundown they must survive and embrace
each other Agatha worried about Sophie
listens to her screams as she navigates
the pretty but deadly flower fields and
the Pumpkin Reaper Fields she transforms
into a pigeon and saves her friend just
in time the reaper charges at them but
Tedros arrives at some point his sword
is separated from him falling close to
Sophie Ted Rose begs her to give him his
sword but she only freezes Agatha does
the job saving all of them Ted Rose
believes Sophie is not truly good in
bales from The Trial Sophie thinks
Agatha is trying to take Tedros away
from her then she also bails Agatha
talks with dovey she convinces her that
raffle is the real threat dubby is
shocked to learn that ROFL has
reappeared and then they go to confront
leso and the other teachers meanwhile
anadil brings Sophie an apology letter
from Agatha raffle appears again
convincing Sophie that Agatha lies he
offers her blood magic which she
willingly accepts Agatha meets with the
School's teachers and they discover
Sophie is missing lesso and dovey
learned that Sophie has learned blood
magic while Sophie admits to them that
she knows lesser was Leonora the missing
girl from gavaldon who fell in love with
rothel and wanted to win his heart
Agatha goes to the ball where she meets
Tedros and asks for Sophie Tedros does
not understand why Agatha is still loyal
to her friend and confesses his love to
Agatha suddenly Sophie appears she
curses the teachers and the school
guards Ted Rose and the good men take
their swords to attack the evil school
as the rule states good does not attack
first only defends once good attacks the
good becomes evil the Nevers then
magically dress as good people and a
great battle ensues Sophie uses her
strong magic to defeat the Good Men
despite Agatha begging her to stop the
madness at some point Sophie leaves the
tower and goes to headmaster's Tower
wanting to avenge him for putting her in
the wrong School the Headmaster turns
out to be rawful disguising himself all
along he kisses Sophie offering her a
place to be his Queen and ruling over
the school with true evil Sophie
realizes his intentions and begs him to
stop as she does not want to hurt her
friends Agatha appears to debunk
rothel's claim that Sophie has been left
alone raffle uses the storian's quill to
stab Agatha but Sophie takes her place
instead with her dying the balance
between good and evil is restored tedro
sneaks up behind rothel to defeat him
but he easily overpowers him with her
dying Powers Sophie moves the Excalibur
tedro's sword so Agatha can use it
against raffle effectively killing him
Sophie dies in Agatha's arms but their
love is so strong that when Agatha
kisses her she revives the school is
restored back to its balance the Deans
agree to unite the school and not treat
good and evil separately the students
Embrace each other as for Sophie and
Agatha they unlock a portal to come home
to gavaldon although Sophie tells Agatha
she can stay in the school with Ted Rose
if she wants to at Agatha wants to stay
with her best friend they come home and
are embraced by each of their families
sometime later they are still mocked by
the villagers but they use their magical
powers to prank the villagers a portal
opens in Ted Rose Arrow flies through
sending them a message that it is only
just the beginning
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching